[Music]
welcome to cloud on air
live webinars from google cloud we are
hosting webinars daily
you are watching cloud 101 where we
discuss the fundamental concept of
google cloud platform
and learn from the best practices in
different markets
my name is anuj and today we will be
talking about how to manage chrome
browser from the cloud
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we have googlers on standby
to answer them
let's get started before we dive in
let's talk about the importance of the
browser the browser is about more than
productivity
with the rise of cloud-based enterprise
applications
more and more enterprise data is flowing
through the browser
that data needs to be secured and
mitigating security risks
is a top priority for enterprises
for some enterprises the need to manage
the browser comes from a compliance or
regulatory perspective
enterprises operating in heavily
regulated markets will often lock down
specific features of the browser
to reduce risk or enforce business needs
with the bulk of enterprise user
activity shifting to the web
the browser needs to play an active role
in the enterprise's security posture
today we'll discuss how the browser
plays a large part in user productivity
and enterprise security
here are the topics that we'll be going
over in our webinar today
first i'll talk about some of the
benefits of managing chrome
and why enterprises are increasingly
making use of chrome's management
features
then i'll cover chrome management
options that we offer today
third i'll introduce chrome browser
cloud management a brand new option for
managing chrome from the cloud
that we're making available for ev to
everyone
and finally i'll walk you through a demo
of its core features
the way we work is changing and the
evolving role of the web and enterprises
has a large part to play in this
more and more work today is done on the
web thanks to the richness of the
enterprise software as a service
ecosystem
that's grown and the web platform that
powers it
in that context the browser is quickly
becoming the centerpiece
for the delivery of business critical
applications
as you can see from the statistics here
both it administrators
and it workers are seeing this shift
first hand
73 percent of enterprises agree that the
browser has become more important to
their it strategy
65 percent of workers report relying
more heavily on their browser today
than they did two years ago so in many
cases it's about making your enterprise
users more productive
that's also where management comes in
administrators can configure the browser
to work
optimally for their environments from
having the right printing defaults
configured automatically
to installing the right extension for
their video conferencing provider
and that's why we need to manage the
browser it's a great way to achieve your
enterprise's productivity compliance and
security goals
chrome supports a very rich set of
browser policies and as
an administrator you have access to
hundreds of browser policies that allow
you to configure
almost any aspect of chrome here are
some examples of where enterprises
often rely on browser policies to
achieve their business goals
first is managing extensions enterprise
admins want to be able to
enable or disable extensions based on
their enterprise needs
control what types of permissions an
extension can request
and send customized messages to
employees when they try to install
extensions that aren't allowed
deploying preset options can make the
browser feel more integrated into your
enterprise
the right certificates proxy settings
and services can be configured by the
admin
so that the browser just works by
default
controlling updates ensures that the
browser is up-to-date
and protected from vulnerabilities and
last but not least
as i mentioned before chrome supports
a very rich set of browser policies and
as an administrator you have access to
hundreds of browser policies
that allow you to control every aspect
of chrome
so today enterprises have two options
for managing chrome
first is to use your platform's existing
management tools to set chrome policies
if you manage windows services you can
set policies using microsoft's
software excuse me microsoft's group
policy objects to configure software on
windows
we offer admx templates to make it easy
to set policies on windows
and we offer options that are
appropriate for mac os
and linux second for enterprises that
already have g suite or have adopted
google identity
those customers can use google admin
console to set user policies
when their users sign into chrome chrome
fetches and applies those user policies
but each of these approaches have their
own set of drawbacks
with existing management tools a simple
apology a policy change
that needs to be applied across windows
mac and linux might take three different
administrators
three different tools and three
different deployment cycles
it's a lot of extra work just to set a
single policy
and also when admins rely on user
profiles
that means that employees have to sign
into chrome to apply the policies
and not every enterprise wants to use
profiles where users have to sign in
to solve these challenges we created
chrome browser cloud management which is
an
easier way to manage chrome deployments
of any size
from a central cloud location across
windows
mac and linux it's also easy to
implement
your end users do not need google
accounts to receive policies
and there is no need for your end users
to sign into the browser
you'll also gain deeper insights into
your deployment
with this new feature admins can
immediately see information about the
policies that are set
the current versions of the browser and
even which extensions are installed
the best part is that all this
information is available from a simple
web console
so if you're an existing g suite
customer you can get started
right away by signing into the google
admin console at
admin.google.com and navigating to the
device management pages
and selecting manage browsers you'll
find instructions on how to enroll
browsers
and get started on that page if your
enterprise has purchased
chrome browser enterprise support or
have
chrome enterprise licenses your admin
console
also has this new service provision
similarly if you've provisioned google
cloud identity
your admin console also already has this
service provisioned
if your enterprise doesn't have g suite
or they don't use
other google services you can still test
this feature
at no charge at the link listed here
we'll also display this information
again at the end of the webinar
so enrolling browsers into chrome
browser cloud management is super easy
once your administrator account is
created you can sign into the google
admin console
navigate to the browser management pages
and create your organizational unit
structure
once your structure is created you can
retrieve your enrollment token for the
organizational unit
that you would like to enroll browsers
into
with that token you will use your
existing tools to set one last platform
policy on the devices
running the browsers that you want to
enroll once that token is set
the browser will enroll itself into the
google admin console
receive browser policies from the cloud
and you can choose to enable the
optional cloud reporting functionality
which will send some information
about the state of your browser
deployment to the admin console
now i'll give you a first-hand look at
the administrator experience
for chrome browser cloud management
in this first video you'll see how to
retrieve an enrollment token from the
console
here the administrator is already logged
into the google admin console
and you'll see them perform a few steps
first they'll navigate to the browser
list page
by locating the manage browser cards in
the device management section
once they've landed on the browser list
page it will list the currently enrolled
browsers
and finally by clicking on the yellow
button they'll retrieve an enrollment
token for one of the organizational
units
that has already been configured
next we'll take a closer look at the
sorting
and filtering options that are available
on the browser list page
from the device list page we can use
search and sorting to quickly get
insight into the state of the fleet
we'll sort by browser version to find
chrome browsers that haven't been
updated in a while
those machines might be good candidates
for applying the forced restart policy
that helps ensure
that chrome stays up to date at a
reasonable pace
in this view we'll go over some of the
browser details that you can obtain
if you choose to turn on the optional
cloud reporting feature
you'll be able to view the extensions
that are installed
which policies are set on the specific
browser
and what plugins are installed
here you can see that the admin has
clicked into
a specific machine and they have a lot
of information available to them
about this machine you can see the
extensions that are installed
which policies are set on this specific
browser
and which plugins are installed
very good information
in our last demo we'll take a look at
the browser extension list page
this page is particularly handy if you
want to get an overview of the
extensions that
your enterprise end users have installed
across your fleet
first we'll look at the browser
extensions list
we can see how many times an extension
has been installed
and we can even force install extensions
you can see we're force installing the
dock extensions
now
next you'll see how to set a new browser
policy in an organizational unit with
chrome browser cloud management
we'll navigate to the browser policy
page
then we'll give you a quick overview of
the types of policies that you can set
and then you can use the search box to
find
cloud reporting user setting and turn it
on
for the whole organization
this will install an optional extension
that you can use to get more insight
into your browser deployment
adding this extension is what gets a lot
of the data and information that you've
been seeing in the demo so far
including the extensions list page
so chrome browser cloud management
enables you to see a ton of data about
your organization
and this service has its own terms that
are compatible with google's
google cloud's other services we also
offer a data export service that allows
you to take your data with you at any
time
deleting a browser results in the
associated information being deleted
from the admin console's storage system
your data is yours to keep
so what's in store for chrome browser
cloud management
well we already support a very rich set
of policies in the admin console
and we want to make even more of the 300
plus policies that we support today
configurable from the cloud in
particular
we want to bring cloud policy controls
for enterprise specific features
such as legacy browser support and for
managing updates
into admin console additionally
we've heard from customers that controls
around enterprise security
such as password alert are important so
we want to bring these features into the
admin console as well
that concludes our quick tour of chrome
browser
cloud management it gives you a quick
way to manage chrome
across windows mac and linux it gives
you great insights into your browser
deployment
and it gives you the ability to delegate
browser management
separately from other management work
you can get started today by visiting g
dot co
chrome cloud management
we also have a wealth of resources to
support you as you deploy
and manage chrome there are two in
particular that i'd like to point out
enterprise release notes we offer a very
rich set of enterprise specific release
notes
at every chrome release if you're an
enterprise admin that wants to stay
abreast of changes in chrome
this is an excellent way to do just that
additionally our website at chrome.com
enterprise contains a ton of information
about how you can manage chrome in your
organization
and with that thank you for attending
our webinar if you'd like to get started
with chrome browser cloud management
please visit g.co chrome cloud
management
thank you for tuning in please visit
cloud on air for more content from
google cloud experts
[Music]
you